hey 42 here for a very short period of
time you were the youngest person in the
world welcome to RIF until 1997 there
were more pigs than people in Denmark
beetles often live within the fur of a
sloth a single sloth was discovered with
over 980
beetles living in its fur in 1993 San
Francisco held a referendum over whether
a police officer called Bob Geary was
allowed to patrol whilst carrying a
ventriloquist dummy called Brendan o
smarty he was in 1923 jockey Frank Hayes
won a race at Belmont Park in New York
despite being dead he suffered a heart
attack mid race but his body stayed in
the saddle until a horse crossed a line
for a 20 to one outside of victory there
is a village in Peru where people settle
the previous year's grudges by fist
fighting then they all start the new
year off on a clean slate Kurt Cobain
shuts himself about one month after
Justin Bieber was born in Washington DC
the Slovakian and Slovenian Embassy's
meet once a month to exchange rumbly
addressed mail when the computer mouse
was invented it was called the XY
position indicator for a display system
until the eighteen hundred's dentures
were often made from the teeth of dead
soldiers tasmania australia has the
cleanest air in the inhabited world when
coca-cola announced a return of cokes
original formula in 1985 ABC News
interrupted General Hospital to break
the story no one knows who invented two
fire hydrants because it's patent was
destroyed in a fire the northern leopard
frog swallows its prey using its eyes it
uses them to help push food down its
throat by retracting them into its head
the first CD pressed in the US was Bruce
Springsteen's born in the USA
fight to the view subscribe for more 42
you